there's a lot of bad news for the
Democrats right now and that's why Tulsi
is getting ahead of it I think
um here is an ABC panel discussing what
Republicans will do if the polls are
this close Terry 30 days to the midterms
less than a month ago the Democrats were
feeling pretty hopeful about their
chances do you still get that sense nope
I think the air went out of that balloon
in part because look the economy is so
tough for so many people food prices
rent spiking if they've got retirement
funds those are evaporating and even the
issue of abortion which did Drive
several special elections and that
remarkable referendum result in Kansas
while there are millions of people for
whom that will be the number one issue I
just think the economic headwinds are so
tough and and Biden is he just doesn't
have the oomph as a candidate anymore
people don't really want him around and
he can't really make his case that I
don't think the Democrats are in any
better place and I would also say in
this country and in other countries
polls are broken right it is clear that
lots of people on the right just don't
answer anymore they were worse in 2020
than they were in 2016. and so you look
at those polls it's close if it's close
it's Republican win
that's interesting because you know you
don't get a lot of good analysis
obviously out of mainstream media but
when I led into the clip I said we were
talking about what Republicans will do I
think one thing that Republicans I think
Republicans Republicans conservatives
you guys got it just sort of not the
brainwashed NPC non-playable character
person they're no longer answering polls
they also usually only poll by a
landline I haven't had a landline in 10
years probably when's the last time you
guys had a land you got a landline over
there no landline no landline no right
so the polling is just completely out of
whack let's remember the polling was
also completely out of whack right
before uh Trump was elected because a
lot of people didn't want to say that
they they didn't want to actually say
they were going to vote for Trump and
then obviously they did uh so the reason
I showed you that clip it's like they
still want to frame mainstream always
wants to frame or corporate press always
wants to frame everything through how
can we sort of save the Democrats that's
the idea there but there's Moran
basically being like look the economy is
so banged up Biden doesn't have bump
right like this thing is so screwed up
he tries to sort of save them a little
bit with abortion but I don't know that
the abortion thing is a winner for
Democrats I don't think that eight-month
abortions is a winner I really don't I
think as I went into quite extensively
yesterday I think some moderate position
on that say 15 weeks like many red
states have including here in Florida is
probably the answer and again I actually
read a bunch of comments yesterday a
bunch of you were saying hey there is no
compromise on abortion murder is murder
I respect that personal belief system
and this is what the uh the complex
nature of having a pluralistic society
is all about we got to fit in all of our
religious and spiritual beliefs and
civil beliefs and how do we match that
with the Constitution and all of those
things